[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an australian action
horror movie called wormwood apocalypse
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
a few years ago several meteors crashed
on an australian wasteland while it
didn't do much harm at first soon the
people started getting sick and killing
each other it turns out that the meteors
brought with them a kind of heavily
contagious virus that transforms humans
into zombie-like creatures except it is
more dangerous because it spreads
through the air as well
no human is immune to the virus but the
ones with blood type a negative can only
be infected with a zombie's bite and not
through the air at the beginning of the
film we are introduced to a girl named
brook who has recently turned into a
zombie she tries attacking her own
people but her brother barry stops her
he gives her a vial of human blood which
turns her back to normal it is then
revealed that brooke is a hybrid zombie
who couldn't complete the full
transformation when she was first
infected she manages to suppress her
zombie urges most of the time but when
it gets out of control she has to take
human blood from the vial because she is
a hybrid she has special characteristics
like she can control fully turned
zombies with her mind brook's brother
barry on the other hand has a negative
blood type and hasn't been bitten yet
which makes him one of the few surviving
humans in the other part of the
wasteland lives a former soldier named
reese he has made the best out of his
situation and is living in a protected
bunker that runs on zombie blood the
zombies secrete a gas from their breath
that is extremely flammable this
component is also found in their blood
which makes it act as fuel reese's day
starts with him exercising and taking a
strange yellow pill then he goes on a
zombie hunt which doesn't take long
since the creatures are surrounding the
fort at all times he captures a few
zombies and makes them components of his
mechanical devices when the creatures
are bribed with meat they move their
hands and legs which reese uses to run
the generators he also practices
fighting with the captured zombies to
maintain his physical strength one day
he finds a zombie hybrid driving his
motorcycle near the fort he takes the
man down and threatens him with a gun on
finding out that the guy is a hybrid
rhys knocks him out and abducts him
after that he brings the man to a lab
set up by the government has the last
resort to find a cure to the virus the
primary researcher is called the spider
who does various experiments on the
hybrids to hopefully find the cure
someday the lab is guarded by many
soldiers to keep it safe from the
enemies rhys frequently brings hybrids
to the lab to help the doctors since he
also wants the world to go back to
normal in turn he is given the yellow
pill they are used to make people
temporarily immune to the virus the
pills are the only reason reese hasn't
been infected yet that day he is given a
picture of two hybrid sisters as his
next target he thinks he is making a
difference in the world by capturing the
hybrids for a better purpose hence he
works hard to find his targets then we
are introduced to the hybrid sisters
maxie and grace they are driving to a
secret hideout when grace's zombie
instinct takes over her body making her
aggressive she tries to hold herself
down but isn't successful maxie helps
her sister at the right time by feeding
her a vial of blood somewhere nearby
rhys is hiding in a field waiting for
the sisters when they are close enough
he makes the first attack and flips
their vehicle grace who is not as
injured as her sister comes outside the
car and fights rhys they engage in an
intense battle but reece being a trained
soldier defeats grace in the end he
doesn't care to check the car for the
second sister and drives away with the
first one a while later maxie comes out
and starts looking for grace only to
find out that she has been kidnapped
rhys's driving grace to the lab when she
suddenly wakes up as a zombie this
multiplies her strength and makes her
attacks more intense she manages to trap
reese but he convinces her to drink
blood that gets her back to normal in
the lab we see the spider use a hybrid
zombie to make a cure that stops the
transformation process temporarily he
injects the medicine into himself but is
caught by the colonel and a soldier in
the process they point their guns at him
for misusing the government resources
but the colonel kills his own man before
the spider is killed it turns out that
the spider and the colonel were bitten
by zombies in the past hence they have
been using the hybrid's blood to make
the medicine that slows the rate of
transformation and keeps them alive
they're fooling everyone because the
hybrids they capture are not being used
for the cure but for their own good as
long as they capture more hybrids and
take the antidote every day they will
not turn into zombies the spider is also
working on a side experiment hidden from
everyone else a while later reece
arrives at the lab and hands grace over
to the colonel before returning home on
the way his car stops and he has to use
a zombie's blood to restart it all this
time maxie is watching him while staying
hidden when he is distracted she jumps
on the back of his car and tags along on
reaching home reese distracts the
zombies with bright light and enters the
bunker at night the lights turn off all
of a sudden reese cautiously comes
outside and restarts the generator only
to come face to face with maxie she
doesn't give him time to react before
knocking him out when he wakes up the
next morning she threatens him to reveal
where her sister is with no way out he
agrees to bring her to the lab on their
drive there maxie finds a picture of
herself in grace and asks him what he
does for a living reese vagley tells her
that he was ordered to bring them to the
lab he distracts her in the conversation
and takes hold of the weapon in the end
maxie is tied to the seat and taken to
the colonel where the soldiers
forcefully take her in the colonel and
reese get into a slight argument when he
makes fun of reese's late brother who
also used to be a soldier the argument
quickly turns into a fight and wreath
shoots the colonel and his soldiers he
runs away but doesn't forget to take
maxie with him they are followed by an
injured colonel and the soldiers who use
their weapons to bring him down when
reese opens his eyes again he finds
himself hung on a tree the colonel
taunts him about his brother's death who
was burned alive by the enemy the person
who killed him was none other than barry
the guy we saw at the beginning of the
movie following that reese's left to the
zombies he tries his best to hold
himself up on the tree but it doesn't
work for a long time a zombie is seconds
away from biting him when they suddenly
freeze a confused rhys looks ahead to
see brooke and her team in front of him
it is revealed that maxie is also
brook's friend she brought them to save
reese since he saved her life earlier
they take him hostage yet again and ask
him to reveal where grace is reese
refuses to say anything and recognizes
barry as the man who killed his brother
brook and the zombies attack the guy
leaving him no option but to cooperate
he tells them everything he knows about
the colonel and the spider he thinks
they are doing a great job by looking
for a cure unaware that nothing of such
sort is happening in the labs a few
hours later the group breaks into the
lab and finds decomposing zombie bodies
it is clear that the doctors are
performing experiments on the zombies
but they cannot let them kill grace they
also see the yellow pells being made out
of the remains of the dead bodies inside
a tank barry finds the corpse of the
hybrid that rhys had brought to the lab
a lab worker reveals that all the
hybrids are killed as part of the
experiment their blood is used to make
an anti-transformation serum for the
colonel while the remains are used to
make the yellow pills reece is shocked
because he was told that they were not
being harmed he realizes that he was
being used and kills the worker in a fit
of rage after finding out the truth
brooke controls a bunch of zombies and
sends them into the lab to kill everyone
when the guards are killed maxie goes
inside a capsule and is dropped into the
bunker she enters a vent and goes
looking for her sister while the others
head inside through the front door to
keep the colonel distracted they kill
everyone in their way while
simultaneously walking towards the
control room where the colonel and the
spider are brooke eventually reaches the
main room and finds the spider inside he
introduces his latest creation the most
dangerous cyborg zombie brook sends her
army of zombies towards the cyborg but
he is too strong for them the spider is
using his arms to control the zombie
which makes him even more dangerous the
real zombies are killed brutally by the
cyborg leaving only brooke alive in the
end he attacks her and throws her to the
wall brook cannot fight the powerful
cyborg and can only hope for a miracle
to save her when he is seconds away from
killing her the said miracle happens and
his hand stops working this is because
grace who is tied in a corner is
controlling the spider's hand and
keeping it from moving the mind control
technique works on him because he is
also half zombie who has been delaying
transformation using the hybrids brooke
gets the upper hand and attacks the
cyborg while the spider is busy with
grace but soon he gets back to fighting
stronger than before brook is yet again
in danger but this time she electrocutes
the cyborg and defeats him before he
even makes an attack
outside barry and rhys are fighting the
colonel since he has a gun he has an
upper hand on both of them he is seconds
away from killing the two when maxie
arrives with her weapon pointed at him
she shoots him dead and saves the others
however things go downhill when brooke
starts transforming into a zombie she
desperately needs a vial of blood but no
one has one when things get out of
control she attacks maxie and makes her
hide inside a cage a while later maxie
finds a pouch of blood and feeds it to
brooke finally calming her down when she
comes back to her senses brooke realizes
that she bit her brother at the same
time the spider gets grace and flies out
through the capsule he also puts the lab
in auto blast mode the group has 30
seconds before the entire lab blows up
and kills all of them barry and brooke
decide to use their blood as fuel to
send reese and maxie outside through the
capsule and sacrifice their own lives
the plan works and recent maxie fly away
seconds before the place explodes and
kills barry and brook outside the spider
is drawing grace's blood for his
antidote right then an ally soldier
finds out that the spider is also a
zombie with no kernel to tell him
otherwise they attack the spider annoyed
by their involvement the spider kills
them both when reese and maxie arrive at
the hideout maxie finds her sister
unconscious and bad rhys confronts the
spider and fights him but since he has
hybrid blood in his veins he easily
overpowers him the man is seconds away
from killing rhys when grace wakes up
and stabs him to death she doesn't stop
there and brutally tears his stomach
open in the last scene maxie gives reese
a yellow pill because he is about to
transform she asks him to join their
team the movie ends with a twist when we
see brooke and barry come out of the
remains of the lab unharmed subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching